hello did you know what Miss Coffee Bean
does outside of YouTube she teaches
machine learning at her University
um I mean to fellow coffee beans in the
coffee machine since Chad GPD came out
she cannot help but Wonder this project
proposal that a student just submitted
was it written by the student himself or
could it be that Chachi PT was behind it
wait was this video script written by
chat GPT we think it is safe to assume
that you sometimes wonder whether an AI
generated a piece of text or not so we
would all like to know that there is a
way to take any text and find out
whether it or parts of it were written
by humans or by language models in this
video we will explain two ways of
detecting AI generated text one is a
tool called gpt0 and the other one is
the idea of watermarking a method that
seems very promising to help with
detecting text generated by language
models such as chat GPT we will explain
both methods and it is up to you to
decide which method you like best but
before we dive into today's topic let's
thank Co here that they are sponsoring
this video given that you're watching
this video about ways to detect AI
generated text we assume you have
already heard about the incredible
advancements of natural language
processing
maybe you thought of including the
latest and greatest large language
models in your applications well then go
here is the right thing for you it lets
you use extremely capable language
models to let them classify text for you
or let them generate documents does this
sound complicated fear not because it is
not at all coher's specialty is to take
the finest Transformer based models like
GPT and birth and let them do the heavy
work for you under the hood all you need
to do is to write these few lines of
code to start generating text you don't
even need machine learning skills to use
cohere just install with peep install
cohere and you are ready to go in Python
they just launched a multilingual text
understanding model that works with over
a hundred languages it has state of the
art results and it is a top performing
embedding model compared to the others
out there you can try out cohere with
their generous free premium developer
upper tier so no credits are needed
users bear no cost until they go to
production you can sign up with this
link also posted in the video
description below before explaining
watermarking we want to see how existing
systems for detecting AI generated
content work so far as an example we
will take GPT 0 since it is a very
popular tool made specifically for
teachers if I take the last part of the
text that Chachi PT generated for that
project proposal then I see that GPT 0
will tell us that the text is generated
by AI the idea behind GPT 0 is to
measure perplexity and burstiness
because these two properties of the text
vary between Machine written content and
human text the first measure is the
perplexity of which you have maybe heard
already in the context of language
modeling it measures how unfamiliar a
produced text is for a model in other
words it is the opposite of the
probability that a sentence was
generated by a language model a high
probability means a low perplexity to
compute the perplexity we go word by
word and we compute how probable it is
for a language model to have generated
it given the previous words
but how to get to these probabilities
the best part is that to build a model
that measures the perplexity or
probabilities of another language model
such as chair GPT one does not need
direct access to chat gpt's weights
access which only open AI has all one
needs is a lot of chat GPT outputs the
more the better this is something that
an API can deliver then one needs to
train a small language model such as
gpt2 to reproduce these chair GPT
outputs in the language model is by
definition a model capable of computing
probabilities for next words given
previous words so after training when
applied to text produced by chargpt the
surrogate model will predict High
probabilities for text produced by chat
GPT and low ones for other kinds of text
and with it we end up Computing
probabilities for the whole sentence by
multiplying all these probabilities we
get the probability of the whole
sentence to be generated by a language
model the perplexity is defined such
that a low probability means a high
perplexity for the model in other words
the language model is surprised by the
text we have given it since there are a
lot of improbable words in it and it
would not have generated them but rather
humans could have written it or other
language models so gpt0 assumes that
human written text has a hyperplexity
for the language model in turn a
language model generated text would have
low perplexity because the high
probability says that it is exactly the
kind of text the model would have
generated the second property that GPT 0
looks at is the so-called burstiness
which measures the sentence complexity
humans vary their sentences a lot when
judging by length and the amount of rare
words they use so the ones on the long
tail of the exception distribution that
describes how frequently we use words
burstiness has something to do with the
fact that for example rare words usually
do not occur very often in our writing
but when they do they start to happen a
lot for a sentence or two then not
anymore language models are more
constant in the way they write out their
sentences so going on sentence by
sentence one can plot the complexity of
each sentence for humans these values
will vary a lot while for models the
value will be quite similar for all
sentences then a bumpy burstinence graph
will likely belong to a human essay
while a more constant graph will belong
to an AI generated essay a problem with
GPT 0 is that it does not always work
and there are ways to fool it into
saying that AI generated text is human
written by introducing spelling mistakes
or tiny grammar errors also what if your
writing has such a low burstiness does
complexity that GPT 0 says it is hey I
written nobody wants to be accused of
that
then how to detect a i generated text
with more confidence with watermarking
where the maker of the model decides
deliver its models text output with a
unique fingerprint that is unnoticeable
for humans but easily detectable with
Statistics as presented in this paper
but as it usually happens good ideas
come from multiple places as highlighted
in a tweet by one of the watermarking
paper authors open AI speaks about a
similar idea already so we will not be
surprised to see watermarking coming to
chagibiti in the future so how does
watermarking work it relies very much on
what happens in a language model when it
chooses which word to predict next so on
the so-called decoding mechanism a
language model beats Transformer based
like GPT or an lstm like older language
models were it's just this thing that
having a sequence possibly empty of
words can predict the probability for
the next word but we want text with the
actual words not a bunch of
probabilities for each word in the
English vocabulary so this is where the
decoding scheme comes in one way to come
up with a word from a probability
distribution over the words is to take
the most next probable word this is
called greedy decoding but this is not
the strategy that modern language models
like to use for decoding because okay
let's suppose we have taken the next
most probable word then the next
Generation step with the language model
we would take the input text the last
prediction and based on this we compute
again probability distributions for the
next words with greedy decoding we would
again take the next most probable word
and so on but this has been shown to
produce very repetitive and unsurprising
text and we humans do not like that we
like to be informed so also a little
little bit surprised by text so there
exists more interesting decoding
mechanisms where one also chooses less
probable words from time to time but
some of the decoding steps but also
ensure a good overall probability it is
here at the decoding step where
watermarking comes in so where we are
sampling the next word from the
predicted probability distribution
we have let's say 50 000 English words
the language model knows about and
predicts the probability for given the
previous words but before choosing the
next word watermarking randomly sets
let's say 20 of all these words to a
blacklist so the language model in
decoding can choose only from the rest
80 percent of the words the seed for the
random number generator that chooses
which words are blacklisted is the last
word of the input in this way The
Blacklist can be reconstructed at any
time this procedure is applied at each
generation of the next token where for
each next word the last word is used as
a seed for again randomly blacklisting
20 of the words in the vocabulary so
these are other Blacklist words than we
have used for generating the previous
word and to detect generated text by
this language model one needs to detect
The Watermark and this is fairly easy
one goes through the generated text and
counts the blacklisted words and we get
a blacklist by knowing the random number
generator used to choose The Blacklist
words and the seed the watermarked
language model would not use blacklisted
words because it can't but a human would
definitely use blacklisted terms so a
text using only white list words is
highly likely to be AI generated and
even a short text can be classified with
relatively High certainty but you will
think that this watermarking procedure
will produce text that looks wrong to
humans because some words just must be
used after others when one says the
quick brown fox jumps then of course the
plausible words there is over since this
sentence is often used for example to
show how fonts look like but if over
gets blacklisted by random sound
sampling then the language model will
produce garbage because it cannot use
the word over where the authors take
care of this by choosing when not to
Blacklist important stuff if the only
high probability to complete the
sentence is the word over then the
probability is computed by the language
model would look like this with a high
probability for over and very low
probability for others this distribution
has low entropy since all of the
probability Mass speaks on this one word
if there were many possibilities to
complete the phrase then the language
model's output will have a high entropy
with the probabilities being distributed
fairly equally among many other words so
the authors make sure to never Blacklist
low entropy words but rather High
entropy cases where the model can choose
other words that are just as good as the
blacklisted words and this was
watermarking in a nutshell the authors
conduct experiments with an openly
accessible model so opt 1.3 billion
million parameters but there's no reason
to believe that this method would not
apply to chat gpt2 they see that the
watermark does not hurt model perplexity
and that the model still generates high
quality text we are curious to see how
if implemented in language models
watermarking will be a reliable
algorithm with no way to fool Miss
Coffee Bean of course there are ways to
fool the watermarking algorithm if it
uses the last token as a random seeds
then anyone can reconstruct The
Blacklist by using the seed and the same
random number generator even if the seed
is kept secret attackers can still brute
force their way to reconstruct The
Blacklist and if one has The Blacklist
all one needs to do is introduce enough
Blacklist tokens which are words that
humans would use but the language model
is not allowed to
but brute forcing their way to The
Blacklist means that the attacker
queries the API a lot of times with the
same input in which case the API
provider can monitor and detect this
malicious activity but now let's talk
about cases of attacks where
watermarking cannot discern whether text
was human or AI written one way to
attack is by doing word substitutions if
humans rewrite content by Chachi PT then
the sentence Rewritten by humans will
not be detected by watermarking but
arguably the text is not written by AI
anymore it was just inspired by it of
course the attacker could also use a
non-watermarked model to paraphrase the
outputs of a watermarked model
changing small things like adding spaces
emojis or misspellings could also affect
the watermark detection but this could
be circumvented by careful application
of text normalization where things like
additional white spaces are removed but
nobody wants to submit an essay full of
misspellings and emojis right a powerful
attack is the Emoji attack it instructs
the language model explicitly to add
emojis or exchange letters in its output
and if the language model is powerful
enough and chat GPT is it will do so
even though the text quality looks bad
at first the attacker can automatically
remove the garbage this would randomize
The Blacklist of words following the
Emojis and would fool watermarking the
authors do not have a solution against
this attack except of training the
language model to refuse to follow such
instructions in the first place so we
see there are some ways to fool even
watermarking but one could still argue
that a watermark is better than no
protection but the clear minus of
watermarking is that it only applies
when people and companies are willing to
Watermark their language models they
produce tools like GPT 0 might be less
reliable at detection but they apply to
language models that are not willing to
do watermarking since training language
models becomes more and more accessible
it is clear that not every language
model out there will be watermarked in
the future unless there will be some
strict regulation about it what do you
think would you feel better if Chachi PT
were to become watermarked or you think
that it is just unnecessary work that
the world doesn't need let us know in
the comments thanks for watching and see
you next time
okay bye
[Music]